ken how do you feel how do you feel
about math are you a madman scribbling
ah no I'm not a man scribble that's just
what a madman would say about his own
yeah no but think about it math is
admittedly one of the most feared
subjects in school the phrase I was
never good at math is probably uttered
more than I was never good at any other
subject writing a curriculum and so what
gives there think of it this way if you
are an athlete if you're training for a
marathon you wouldn't just expect to be
fast at you'd have to practice right and
so um I think the reason people often
say they're not good at math is because
there's this belief that if you're good
at math you were just born with it and
that's just like so untrue right so how
do you how do you convey to people that
you just encounter in the street that
math is something beautiful well I don't
actually do that for a living I an
astrophysicist right can grab anybody by
the lapels in the street right and tell
them something completely beautiful
about the universe and I think they will
agree with my sentiment on its beauty
that's right okay can you do that with
math ah well not you okay so let me give
an example yeah let me tell you
something you probably didn't know so
every March we celebrate pi day pi day
March 14th and by the way I'm wearing a
PI tie well okay so here's the thing
there even fewer more time okay
so while you're showing your time so
they're people that even memorize like a
hundred digits of pi or a thousand
digital my son did that once it cut out
of confetti is a little weird
that's weird and so I think something is
beautiful when you get patterns out of
things that are like you don't expect to
see patterns out of like serial killers
so check this out kill me powder you're
exactly right
soon they talk about in the pre police
prank the precinct but what Beth so
getting back to PI so Ramanujan was one
of the people who could tame Pi and
believe it or not he could tell you
exactly what PI was by just running down
the odd numbers in order one three five
seven nine eleven he gave a procedure to
exactly calculating PI so you said he
tamed yeah it's not true that 3.13 pi is
3.14159 Deven chily nobody knows if
you're willing to be creative and think
of rethink how you would write down that
number Ramanujan showed you a and it
only took so I think we've got an image
of one of us hope it's a PI let's check
it out there you go do you see all those
squares one three five seven nine
everyone knows what comes next
eleven followed by thirteen that's all
other way to write PI this is actually
how I would write pi and it's beautiful
the three-point the whoomp one four one
five mess that's that sequence of one
squared three like an infinite fraction
goes on forever but it there's no
there's nothing hard about remembering
that pattern I can't wait to show that
to somebody it I think